hi and welcome to our session today
my name is chris latimer i'm one of the
product managers here at google cloud
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about building and managing apis for
serverless with google cloud
they're going to be five things we're
going to look at today we're going to
start
off by looking at how we can build
services we're going to use the cloud
code plugin
that gcp provides to developers to make
it easy to get started with
gcp development we're going to look at
how we can deploy those services to
cloud run
and then we're going to look at how we
can combine multiple services together
to form an api
using gcp's brand new api gateway which
is just announced in beta
once we have that api created we're
going to see how we can secure that api
and then finally once everything's up
and running we're going to take a look
at how we can monitor that api
using cloud logging and cloud monitoring
so that if anything's not working the
way we expect we can get alerted
uh to that fact
for our first step we're going to look
at how we can build services
we're going to use the cloud code plugin
that comes with
intellij now you could also use visual
code if that's your
if that's your preferred ide now there
are a few steps that i've already taken
ahead of time so i've already installed
intellij
i've already installed the cloud code
plugin i also have installed docker and
the gcloud cli
so if you're going to follow along you
may want to do the same steps on your
workstation so let's jump into the demo
and take a look at how we can build
a service using the cloud code plugin
and then get that deployed to cloud run
to get started in intellij we're going
to select create a new project
and we are going to select the cloud run
option that comes with the cloud code
plugin
and i'm going to pick the java version
we'll give this a name we'll call it
customers api
and click finish once this is done
intellij is going to look at the project
structure it's going to detect that we
have
a maven palm file we can add that palm
file and
switch this over to a maven project now
inside of intellij
that's going to give us all the standard
maven features that we'd want
if we take a look over at the code base
we'll see that within the file system
the cloud code plugin has given us a
good starting point
it gives us a spring boot app that will
run right out of the box
so if i configure my sdk and tell
intellij i want to use
java 11
i can then click over here on this
spring boot
and select the spring boot run option
this is going to start my application
locally
and so after a few seconds this is going
to come up
and it's going to start successfully and
we can verify that by looking over here
at the
log messages that are printed to the
console
we see that it successfully started now
listening and accepting traffic
if i come into my browser now and i hit
localhost 8080
we can see that this app is in fact
running
so right out of the box we can get a web
application working but what we really
want is we want a micro service that we
can deploy to cloud run
and so rather than walk you through the
individual steps of how to create an api
inside of spring boot which is well
documented elsewhere on the internet
i have already pre-configured this in my
git repository
so i'm going to start off by checking
out a tag here called
basic api and then once i do this we can
go back into the ide
and here if we look at the file system
we're going to see now that instead of
the web app we have
a controller an entity and a service
inside the controller you can see this
is a rest controller
it has a single mapping to slash
and the way that we are going to process
these incoming requests is we're going
to use a service called customer service
looking inside here this is just a mock
service so i don't have a database
behind here
but it is going to populate a list of
entities a list of entities called
customer
that has a number of different fields
associated with it we can now run this
the same way that we did before so we'll
use the spring boot
plug-in use the run target again we're
going to see
messages printed out here to the console
and after a few
seconds we're going to see one that says
that our app is
started successfully and if we look
scroll over here to the right we
do see that same message so once that's
started
we can come now over into the terminal
window
and let's issue a curl command on
localhost
8080. we could pretty print this json
with the python
json tool and there we go
our api is successfully now running
locally here on my workstation
now we're ready to deploy our
microservice into cloud run so let's
click on edit configurations up here
this is going to bring up a form that
comes with cloud code
we can pick our gcp project we can pick
our region that we want to deploy
our service into we can select a service
name and then whether we want to have
authentication or not
in this case we do so we'll select that
last thing we need to specify
is where we should upload this container
image in this case we're going to use
the
google container registry so we'll give
it a name here of
customers api and note that my project
is also specified here also important to
note that i've already pre-enabled the
google container registry on my project
before
i started this demo so you may get an
error if you try to upload this and you
haven't
enabled that service on your project now
let's go ahead and save our
configuration here
and now let's run it so as this runs
it's essentially going to do all the
steps that we need to actually get our
container up and running
on cloud run so it's going to build a
container locally
it's going to interact with gcr it's
going to create the necessary tags that
it needs
if it finds the container in the cache
it's not going to rebuild it
and then it's ultimately going to deploy
this to cloud run
and after a few seconds here what we
should see is that it'll come back and
say
it's deployed and now accepting traffic
and
traffic is going to be accessible via
this url that you see right here
now remember we secured this api and so
if we come back to the terminal window
and we try to curl that url we're going
to get a message saying that your client
does not have permissions to
essentially to make this call and that
was back here on this configuration
where we said require authentication if
we had said allow
unauthenticated connections then we
would have been able to access this api
just fine as
is but we really want the gateway to be
that entry point into our api so we want
to say
we want to tell cloud run to
authenticate these requests
so that all of our clients have to come
through the gateway and the only
authenticated client that's going to be
able to call
into our cloud run back indirectly is
going to be the gateway
so we see that the api has been deployed
we can hit it here locally using curl
but let's jump over to cloud console
and just verify that everything looks
fine there we'll navigate down to cloud
run
and just as expected we see the customer
api
deployed green checkbox next to it
everything is looking good here
so let's jump back into the presentation
and recap what we've seen so far
all right so coming back from the demo
let's take a look at what we just saw
the first thing we saw is how to get
started using the cloud code plug-in
this set up a nice workspace for us they
set our file system up so that we had
all of the
pieces that we needed to start building
our actual service that we're interested
in
we took that initial starting point and
we used it to create a nice restful
service using spring boot
and then once we were satisfied that
that was running locally the way that we
wanted
we configured the ide to deploy that
into cloudrun once that was there we saw
that the deployment worked successfully
and now we have our service up and
running
exactly as we hoped it would and so
currently this is what
our cloud instance looks like we have a
single customer
api that's running in cloud run and if
we wanted to
we could have a client uh make calls
directly to this
this service if all we had was a single
service and a single client this is not
such a bad option we could create a
service account
we could give that service account to
the client they could make calls
and uh everything would work you know
pretty pretty good
the problem that's going to happen is
that as we start adding more and more
services
we're putting more of a burden on our
client they're going to have to remember
which service is responsible for which
piece of functionality
they're going to have to route to the
right place each time
and that can be inconvenient it can also
be inconvenient for
us as the api providers because now we
have to think about who we're going to
break whenever we make a change
what would be better is if we could put
a single api facade in front of these
services so that
for our clients we can give them one
consistent interface that they can use
and we can insulate ourselves from those
clients we have flexibility to scale and
deploy and make changes to our back-end
services
without worrying that our clients are
going to need to change
so let's jump into our next demo and
take a look at how we can
use services that are deployed onto
cloud run
put an api gateway in front of those to
create one consistent
api facade for our clients so let's jump
back into the cloud console here and
navigate to cloud run
like we showed on the presentation we
want to be able to have an api gateway
that's going to sit in front of multiple
services
so that our api clients don't have to
worry about which service
to route which requests do we just want
them to have one nice api facade that
they can call into
and we want api gateway to handle both
the security on that api
as well as the routing so that we send
those requests to the right service on
the back end
to configure api gateway we need to have
an open api specification file
and it needs to have all of the
resources in our api
so in this case you can see that we have
a customer's resource and accounts
resource and an orders resource
once we have that set up we need to
configure
the value for host now this may be a
little bit
um surprising if you're if you're used
to using
open api the value that we're going to
put here in the host field is going to
be a combination
of the identifier that we want to use
for the api
here in this field called api id as well
as our project
and this is going to conform to the
standard
service naming structure that's used
within google
so for right now just think about this
as this is just the format that you have
to follow don't think too much about why
this format is the way it is this is
just the way that api gateway gets
configured
and then here on the title field we want
to put in that same
api id and we'll see in later steps that
we're going to
that this value that we put in for title
is going to show up when we go to create
an api key and when we go to restrict
that key
to only be able to call certain services
once we have host and title configured
the next thing to do is to add in
routing instructions for api gateway so
for each of these resources we're going
to use the x google backend that you see
here and we're going to put in an
address that corresponds to the correct
service that's running in cloud run so
for example
for the customers resource we want to
route to the customer service
so how do we do that first thing that we
have to know is the address for each of
our services on cloud run
and so to find the address that we want
to route to we can navigate back to
cloud console
and find the service that we're
interested in and if we
click on the service it's going to bring
us to a more detailed view and you can
see that right up here
we have the address where the service is
accessible
and we can copy this to our clipboard
and then we will jump back to the ide
and back to our open api specification
and then here
on the address field we'll just simply
paste this in so here's our
our address for the customer service
that's currently running on cloud run
next we'll do that exact same thing for
the account api we will
grab its url from cloud run we'll come
back to the ide and paste that value in
the address field here
then we'll go back to the cloud console
again this time grabbing our orders api
copy the location for this service
and just like before we'll paste that
into the address field here
at this point our open api specification
is ready to go
and we can use this to create a new api
inside of api gateway to do that we're
going to go to cloud console we're going
to
navigate down to the api gateway option
and we're going to click on create api
here we're going to give our api a
display name we'll call it ecommerce
api and we need to use the same api
id here that we used in our open api
specification so we called it ecommerce
there we need to make sure we call it
e-commerce here as well
now this step takes a little while to
complete it's usually one to two minutes
or so for it to
get done and then once it does wrap up
we're ready then to upload our open api
specification that we just created so
click on browse we'll find
the file in our file system and once we
do
we'll select that open api
file and then we'll give our
configuration here a display name this
will just show up on the list when we go
to the ui
and then we're going to select the
service account that we want to use to
connect to
that backend to the cloud run services
that we are routing to
so again this step is going to take you
know around 30 seconds or so to complete
and then once this wraps up we'll be
able to deploy
our new api config to an api gateway
so just like before we're going to give
our api gateway a display name
we'll call it the commerce api gateway
and pick a location we'll use us central
that's where all of our cloud run
services are deployed
click create and there we go it's
created
i can now click on this api and if i do
i'll see that
i have a gateway associated with it this
is deployed and
this gateway is accepting traffic at the
url that you see listed under gateway
url here
now i can take this url i can go to my
browser
and i can just simply issue a request
and i'll call the gateway url
customers and voila there we go we get
our data back from our customers api
so now let's jump back into slides and
let's recap what we saw in this demo
all right so what do we see in that demo
well we started off
with our open api specification and we
started off by defining all the
resources that our api is going to
expose to the clients
and then we configured api gateway with
the parameters that api gateway needs
and that was really our api
id our title and our project id
and then finally we updated each of
those resources to point to the correct
service on cloud
run so that when an api call comes in
it's going to be routed to the right
place
once we had our open api spec all ready
to go
we went back into pantheon and we
configured api gateway
now you saw that there were a few steps
that we went through and one of those
steps is we uploaded
our open api specification and we
created an api config
and in the demo we just created one and
we took that one api configuration and
we deployed
it directly to the api gateway but apis
can actually have multiple
configurations associated with them
and this can be pretty useful for a
number of use cases if you're doing
something like api versioning
or you're building up an sdlc maybe
you're going to have a different
configuration
in your test versus dev versus prod
environment api configs can help you
to solve those use cases and right now
after our demo this is what our
environment looks like we have three
different services that are running on
cloud run
we have an api gateway now with an api
called ecommerce that's fronting those
services and then our clients are now
have a consistent interface that
they can call into to access any pieces
of those services that are running in
cloud run
now it's just one problem that api is
wide open to the internet so anyone at
this point can make a call to our api
and it's going to respond with data so
what we'd like to do
is we'd like to put in place some
security so that not just anybody can
call into our api but
only clients that we authorize and so
why don't we jump back into the demo and
look at how we can use api gateway
to add api key security to provide a
more
secure api for our clients
to configure api security we're going to
come back to our open api specification
and
as you can see i have a new security
definition that i've already added
it has a type of api key it has a name
of key and
it has an n value of query so what this
means is that
i'm going to look for an api key i'm
going to look
for a query parameter called key and
that's what i'm going to interpret
as the api key now i need to then go to
each individual resource
and i need to add in a security
definition and i'm going to just simply
reference that api
key that i had in the security
definition above and what this is going
to do
is it's going to then require any
incoming
api calls to either provide a valid api
key that's been authorized to use this
resource or else it's going to reject
the call
now that we've configured security
within our open api specification we can
come back here to the cloud console
and we can find the same ecommerce api
and the same api gateway that we created
in the previous demo
and we need to create a new api
configuration so to do that let's go to
the config tab that you see here
and we're going to click on upload
config just like we did in the last demo
we're going to click on browse we're
going to find that open api
specification that we just created with
our security definitions in it
we're going to select that file and
upload it now we'll give it a new
display name here as well we'll call
this one e-commerce
secure config and then just like before
we're going to
select the service account that we're
going to use to authenticate the calls
to
cloud run we'll pick the same gateway we
could have created a new gateway here as
well but we're going to
just override the config that was
deployed to that existing gateway
and we will wait for around 30 seconds
or so while our
configuration is uploaded and deployed
to that new gateway
and after patiently waiting for a few
seconds here
we will see that this step will complete
successfully
as soon as this step wraps up our
configuration is live and is deployed to
our api gateway
so just like we did in the last demo we
can come back over here to our browser
window and we can
issue a request to our gateway url
customers
but this time we're going to get a
different response last time we got back
data we got back customer data
this time we're getting back an error
message saying hey this api is expecting
you to provide an api key but you didn't
provide one
so now let's take a look at what we need
to do to get valid credentials that we
can call this api
if you recall when we were very first
setting up our open api specification i
said we're going to use this api
id and we're going to put that id into
the title field
so let me show you exactly how that
title value
is going to be important to api
consumers
before we can get a valid key to call
our api we need to enable this api
within our gcp project and the way we're
going to do that is we're going to come
here to the api's and services dashboard
click on enable apis and services
and that title that ecommerce title is
what we're going to search for
and that's the api that we're going to
find right here
and once this pops up we can click on
enable
it's going to take a few seconds it's
going to say this is not a google api
and give you a little warning there
but after a few seconds it's going to
then be enabled on our project
and once it is we can then navigate
over to the apis and services
credentials section
and we can create a new credential in
this case it's going to be an api key
that key is created and then we're going
to want to restrict that key otherwise
it's going to give us access to
everything
once we click on restrict key we're
going to see a list of services we can
select from now because we enabled the
e-commerce api we're going to see
ecommerce in that list and now
this key that we're generating is only
going to be good
for making calls to our ecommerce api
now we can click here and we can copy
our key to a clipboard
and then we'll jump back to the browser
where we had the error before and let's
put in a query parameter called
key equals api key and there we go
now we're getting back data instead of
the air our api is secured we have a way
to get credentials and a way to get
access to our api
so now let's jump back into slides and
let's recap what we did and what we saw
in this demo
all right so great we've set up our api
gateway we've configured it
to point to our cloud run services and
now we've added security on top of it
so we're done right um well in a sense
yes but if this were a real production
api
as you know we're going to have to
actually operate and maintain and manage
this thing and a big part of that is
going to be monitoring our api to make
sure that it's working the way we expect
so why don't we jump into our next demo
now and take a look at how we can use
cloud logging and cloud monitoring to
set up an alert so that something's
going wrong with our api
we'll get alerted about it
for our last demo we're going to take a
look at how we might monitor apis
so to do that we're going to come down
here to the operation section
of the cloud console menu pick
monitoring and then
alerting underneath the monitoring menu
to start off we're going to create a new
policy and let's talk a little bit about
what types of things we might want to
monitor we might want to look at things
like
air rates that are creeping up too high
we might want to look at
the amount of traffic that's coming
through our api or in this case what
we're going to show
is how we can monitor the back-end
latency
and get alerted if all of a sudden our
backend for api
is taking longer to respond than a
specific threshold
let's start by giving our alerting
policy a name we're going to call it
slow back ends
and then we're going to add a condition
first thing we need to do is define the
right
resource that we want to monitor now for
api gateway
all of the resources and metrics that
we're going to report are going to be
underneath
the produced api resource so that's what
we're going to select here for our first
condition
once we've selected that resource we can
pick from a number of metrics
in this case we're going to pick request
back-end latency
from here we need to select the
aggregator we could look at things here
like the 50th percentile
95th percentile in this case i'm going
to pick the 99th percentile because
i want to understand what the worst
latency the consumers are experiencing
and then the last thing that we're going
to need to do under configuration is to
set a threshold
uh i'm going to set it pretty low just
to 10 milliseconds just to make sure
it's going to be
easy for us to trigger this alert and we
can verify that it's working
and then the very last thing we'll do is
we'll just click on add
and then that will bring us back to our
main
create alerting policy form here and the
next thing we're going to need to do is
to set up
a notification channel we have different
types that we can choose from i'm just
going to do a very simple
notification channel here of email and
i'm going to enter my own email address
in here
we'll click on add and then that's going
to be it we could add documentation if
we want
but i'm just going to click on save and
now at this point our alert is created
and our next step is going to be to
start generating some traffic to see if
we can trigger this alert
and make sure that we're getting an
email if our latency start to creep up
so all we have to do to generate load
let's just come back over to the browser
we were using before and we're just
going to start hitting
our backend with just a whole bunch of
api calls we'll just
keep smashing the refresh button and
sending those api calls
and hopefully that will be enough to
trigger an alert here before too long
if we go back to the monitoring ui now
and refresh we should see a new alert
that's popped up
and we do if we click on this we'll be
able to get some details about the alert
exactly what happened what was the
latency that we were seeing
verify that it did exceed the threshold
and then if i go to my inbox
i'll also see that i did get notified
about this
alert being triggered and now if i were
the person responsible for monitoring
this api and operating this api
i could go dig into this and figure out
what's going on and we could take
corrective action to make sure that
we correct any problems that are
occurring hopefully this gives you a
good idea for how you can set up
monitoring and alerting for apis that
are managed by api gateway
and with that let's jump back into
slides and recap what we saw here in
this demo
right so now we've seen how to build
apis we've seen how to secure those apis
and now we've seen how to monitor those
apis and make sure that we're going to
get an alert if anything's not working
correctly
so we hope that through this demo in the
presentation you've got a taste for what
you can do
with our new api gateway product which
again we just recently announced in beta
i wanted to spend a little bit of time
talking to you about the things that we
have on our roadmap and where we see
this product
evolving over the coming months so
the first thing to talk about is api
gateway and how we see this serving
gcp customers if you're someone who's
building web apps you're building mobile
apps or multi-experience apps that are
using
apis on gcp we really want to make that
process a lot easier for you
not only just routing to things like
serverless but also helping you compose
apis so if you have data that's in
bigquery you have data that is running
on serverless or nostrils compute
maybe even data that's in your data
center that you want to connect to
via vpc we want to make that process
extremely easy for you
if you're building out apps that need
authentication and you want to use
things like google cloud's identity
platform we're working closely with
those teams to bring you a solution
that's going to make it much much easier
to build those applications on top of
google cloud
now specifically in our short term we
have a few enhancements that i'd like to
make you aware of
we've had an overwhelming amount of
demand for
open api v3 support and we've heard you
loud and clear
our team is working hard to implement
open api b3 for api gateway
we're expecting to have something out
for you in the very very first part of
2021 we're also working to integrate
with the google cloud load balancer
and that's going to do a couple things
that's going to give you the ability to
configure integration with
products such as cloud armor so if you
need ddos protection you need os top 10
protection
ip filtering and so forth it's going to
be a great solution for you
as well as integration with our cloud
cdn for
for caching those responses for those of
you that are more interested in full
lifecycle api management we're working
really closely with the apogee team as
well
to bring you integration with apigee
features such as api products
and apogee's developer portals so on
behalf of the entire
team here at gcp especially the
serverless team
the apogee team and the api gateway team
we are so thankful for you taking the
time to watch our session here today
and we really look forward to getting
your feedback on the product
thank you so much
you